when I first arrived more place I found
a restaurant in crisis very simple it
felt more like a rest home today I have
a book full of loving people deep fried
microwave more out of a packet that's
[ __ ] seventies crap at its best
too many cooks are not one of them any
good playing [ __ ] I'm not hungry
and I met possibly the worst waiter the
world
I mean really [ __ ] shocked but by the
end of the week things that started to
improve
that was in March 2004 now I'm back to
find out and heading up the kitchen I
wasn't to arrive it's still purple
priorities we've continued to spend
money here it's on the list some stage
oh yes remember the last chat we had the
dollar to get in the restroom busy was
the sort of objection behind the whole
thing that was stood in the set menu and
dropping the price down and ever since
then it's probably settled in a 60 70
percent higher than it was before
regardless so now it's an executive
barman we could give an undies head only
to the menu and get on with it the one
thing I would say categorically the food
here is great
the product is great but the proof is in
the pudding over at least seems to have
improved on that flat pancake he made me
last time I was here it's not bad you
know it's actually not bad little bit
too thick at the bottom and needs more
salt do you do it okay sure
it doesn't use coarse [ __ ] Nazi thank
you that [ __ ] exciting